welcome to this video yeah this is
coverage from round round game ninth
game nine of the World Championship
match between cars in and Ireland and
Carson is leading by one point and yeah
the Challenger has to score a win at
some point difficult to do with black
but let's see what happened today to be
honest I don't want to make a big fuss
out of this game at this video you see
the playing time of the video and it is
simply the case that we don't really
have a game here I can show you that
they played the balloon again which is
kind of an interesting decision by a
hard I'm offering again this kind of
dull opening should he play sharper with
black hmm maybe it yeah afterwards in
hindsight is 2020 yeah is it should we
play sharper should be like he does
obviously try to score with white and be
content with black to have a draw I
don't know well we got this and this is
the same as in Game mom in Game seven
where Carlton had this this long long
pressure that didn't break through we
have a different line now with 92 and
I'm not an expert on the berliner don't
intend to become one just because i need
to do commentary on this really a boring
game so i can tell you that they can
came to this point where white has
played e6 and yeah i mean the thing is
why it is sort of threatening should
take or i have seven plain ig5 so Bishop
d6 is the the move from the normal
movement after that why i took gave the
check here yeah and now the only
sensible move is really king f6
attacking this this night on on
on g5 yeah you don't want to go back I
mean what kind of move was that yeah
yeah that looks ridiculous and probably
has some concrete problems like 96 for
example and then ruge age six but well
it's it's impossible really now if you'd
like to do anything else but king of six
and after Kiev six I have this check and
began a check and they're gonna check
and hear the game was over so we really
had a non-game today how to how to
assess this I mean besides the fact that
it's a big disappointment for for the
spectators yeah so uh not really seems
to to to put all his effort into the
white games he has two white games left
and in most of the white games he had
some pressure so it's not like he didn't
get anywhere in the earlier rounds um
yeah and Carlton seems to be content
with a quick draw with white being
confident it seems that he can hold the
last three games that's a very pragmatic
approach I mean he did something similar
in the match last year where he sort of
played one totally lifeless draw with
white and it was also in the Berlin um
and but at that point he led by two
points so not by just one point so it is
a kind of a risky strategy to just allow
it wrong maybe it wasn't so yeah I don't
know maybe he didn't really plan to do
this from the from the get-go um but it
sort of happened and he had to be honest
once we you are in this position here
it's not so easy to deviate because
while King l6 you sort of have to give
the check I mean yeah other moves don't
make me make much sense and here they
are how does white continue black has
the two bishops and it is really not the
case that you can do something great
here I mean if you don't give the check
what do you play I mean black is ready
to get his
into play groupie a Dorsey 5 you can
easily get the worst position if you try
something here and if white intended to
fight he needed to do it earlier but I
really don't cannot evaluate the
theoretical value of this this game um
this is a well-known draw someone that
can someone deviate them with some which
makes some sense the deviation hard hard
to tell yeah well it's a very very
boring thing to to look at certainly so
what do we get we get three games um
that then I left to two unarmed games
under test white in the last game which
i think is in this case quite good for
him so even if he comes it comes to the
situation that he's down one point he
can try to win the final game and force
a tie-break and I mean I think
definitely this she looks and better
shape then then last last year where it
was really a very one-sided affair so
I'm not totally convinced that it is an
easy going for for Carlton also I have
the slight suspicion that he's not in
one hundred percent physical shape he
looked very very tired and in the game
before that in Game aid and I don't know
maybe he's not really totally fit they
have fun the opportunity in case of a
real illness to to consult a doctor and
then they sort of get it get a day off
but you really you have to be really ill
to to do that so like a fever or whatnot
maybe it's it's something that that
simply just happened to people and you
get to let's say what i had last weekend
i got some sort of a stomach bug virus
whatnot and i assure you that i wasn't
in any position to play chess or even
think straight and this is not the kind
of thing that you can use to get a day
off here you need something really
serious you never know the the what is
behind happening behind the scenes yeah
there have been the spin this world
champion should mention 2004 between
chromed again lake over Kramnik was so
ill that he had to take heavy medication
all the time but he still couldn't there
was no there was no way to postpone
games then if i'm not mistaken yeah so a
disappointing game today but let's hope
that the white games by wish you will be
more interesting the next one being
tomorrow yeah thanks for watching anyway
and it's not it's not in my not in a
position to change anything about the
game content okay well thanks for
watching I'm back tomorrow with game
game 10 it is so thanks